the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu ok let's get started so what
we are going to do today is go about
discovering other alternative methods we
know you guys are amazing hackers and
you can actually do all those things by
hand but to make a multi-course
generally acceptable can we do things
automatically can you really reduce a
burden from the programmers so i am
going to at the beginning i am going to
talk about general parallelizing
compilers what people have done what's
the state of the art can you get you
feel what is doable and hopefully that
would be a little bit over and then we
will go talk what stream it compiler
something little what we have done
recently and how this automation part
can do so I'll talk about a little bit
about parallel execution this is kind of
a what you know already and then go into
parallelizing compilers and talk about
how to determine if something is
parallel by doing data dependence
analysis and how to increase the amount
of parallelism available in code what
kind of transformations and then we go
look at how to generate code because
once you realize something is parallel
how do we actually get to run parallel
and finish up with actually how do you
do communication code in machine such as
a cell so in parallel execution this is
something it's a review so there are
many ways of parallel some things like
instruction level parallelism it's
basically extracted by hardware or
compiler scheduling and as of today this
is in abundance I mean all super scale
as we do that in Vienna w/e do that then
Tassler parallel some it's what most of
you guys are doing now and you probably
find the program you've divided in task
you get task parallelism mainly by hand
some of you might be doing data level
parallelism and also loop player
parallelism and that can be the hand Oh
compiler generated and then of course
pipeline parallelism is more mainly done
in hardware and language Xtreme 82
parallelism and then divide and conquer
parallelism we went little bit more done
in Hardware I'm editor in hand for
recursive functions today we are going
to focus on loop parallelism
specifically how to do loop parallelism
by the compiler so my loops loops is
interesting because people have observed
in most code ninety percent of execution
time is in ten percent of the code
almost ninety nine percent of the
execution time is in ten percent of the
code and these code are loops and it
makes sense because at running at Riga
hurt if only run one instruction once
then you run through your hard drive in
only a few minutes because you need to
have repeatability and Laura time repeat
abilities in loops and loops if we can
paralyze you can get really good
performance because loops most of the
time eat loop iteration have the same
amount of work and you get a nice good
load balancing see something somewhat
easy to analyze and so that is why the
compiler start there whereas if you try
to get Tassler parallelism things have
lot more complexities that automatic
compiler cannot do so there are two
types of parallel loops one is a four or
loop that means there are no loop
current dependences that means you can
get the sequential code executing
parrilla run everything in parallel and
at the end you have a barrier and when
everybody finishes you continue on this
equation code and that is how you do a
forward loop and some languages in fact
have explicitly parallel constructed
okay here's a for all loop and go do
that the other type of loop is called
for cross or do a cross loop that says
okay by the loop is parallel there are
some dependences that means some value
generated here is used somewhere here so
you can run it parallel but you have
some communication going through so so
you have to move data so it's not
completely running parallel there's some
some synchronization going on
but you can get large championing
parallel so we kind of focus on do all
loops today and let's look at this
example this is a 4 pi so it's a
parallel loop 04 or loop and when you
know it's Turner in here of course the
user said that what we can do is we can
distribute decorations by chunking up
the iteration space into number of
processor chance and basically run that
and in spm d mode you can at the
beginning the first processor can
calculate the number of iterations you
cannot only processor in here and then
you synchronize you put a barrier there
so everybody kind of sync up at that
point or the other process of waiting
and at that point you everybody start
everybody when you reach this point
running its parts of iterations and me
are done you're going to put a barrier
synchronization and some kind of obvious
bread-and-butter parallel code basically
running on a shared memory machine at
this point okay so this is what what we
can do I mean this is what we saw before
so and of course you can instead of
doing that you can also do fork joint
type so once you want to run something
parallel you can focus read and eat get
some amount of iterations you run and
after that you merge together so you can
do both so that is my hat so how do you
do something like that by the compiler
that sounds simple enough trivial enough
but you don't automate the entire
process how do you go about doing that
so here are some normal rules for loops
so the for all does this thing that that
was so simple which is the for all
construct that means some would actually
look at that and say this loop is
parallel but if you look at these four
loop how many of these groups are
parallel is the first loop parallel why
why not
this is a loop current dependence
because this the creation one of that is
using what you wrote in iteration zero
so you tration one has to wait
alliteration zero is done so on so for
how about this one why any 1025 is
trading anyone 6 to 11 so they don't
overlap so what you read and what you
write I never overlap so you can keep
doing it in any order because they're
the dependence means something you wrote
later yoga read is the snapple about
this one
why every evening
so you are writing even you are reading
on so there's no overlap in question so
the way to look at that I am going to go
a little bit of formalism you can think
about this as a iteration space so
iteration is if you look at each
children separately there could be
thousands and millions of iterations and
you compile an evolution doing anywhere
and also some titration space is defined
by range like one to n so you don't even
know exact how many iterations are going
to be there so you can stay present this
as abstract space and normally most of
these loops you look at it a normalized
to step one so we so what that means is
all the integer points in that space
there so if you have a loop like this y
equal 0 to 6 j equals 1 I 27 that's the
iteration space there are two dimensions
in there and the points that start
iteration of course it's not a
rectangular space it can have this that
shape because jay is going triangular in
here so the way you can represent that
is you can impress racial space by a
vector I and and you can have each
dimension so this is 2 dimension this
was have I 1 I 2 space in here so you
cannot present like that and there's a
notion of what you called lexicographic
ordering that means if you execute the
loop what's the order you are going to
visit this thing if you execute this
loop what you're going to do is you go
from j you go like this you go this is
lexicographical ordering of we seek in
the loops okay that's that's the normal
execution order that's a sequential
order and at some point you want to make
sure that anything we do kind of has a
look and feel of the sequential
lexicographical order so one thing you
can say is if you have multiple
dimensions if one dimension is if you
have two iterations if one iteration Lex
then the lexicographic Alex and other
iteration says if all the outer
dimensions are the same you go to the
first dimension we are the numbers they
are in two different iterations and and
then that dictates if it is less
effective less than the other so the
outer dimensions are the same
means the next one decides next one
decide next one decides going down and
the first one that actually difference
besides who's before the other one so
another concept is called affine
lewdness if I lupinus case loop bounds
are integer linear functions of Kern's
constants and a loop constant variable
and outer loop indices so that means if
you if you want to get a fine function
within a loop that has to be a linear
function no integer function we are all
the things he there has to be constants
or loop constants that means that that
variable doesn't change in the loop or
outer loop indices because that makes it
much easier to analyze and and also
array accesses each the dimension access
function has the same property so of
course there are my mini program that
does not satisfy this for example if you
do FFT that does not satisfy that
because you have Exponential's in there
and but what that means is a 50 this
probably no way that a compilers can
analyze that but but most kind of loop
feed this kind of model and it then you
can put it into nice mathematical
framework can analyze that so what I'm
going to go through is kind of follow
through some of that mathematical
framework with you guys so what you can
do here is if you look at this one
instead of keep representing this
iteration space by each iteration which
can be huge oh which is not even known
at compile time what you can do is you
can represent this by a kind of a
bounding space of the iteration night
relations basically so what he says we
don't read mark every box there but we
say okay look if you put these planes I
put four planes in here in everything
inside this flames represent this
iteration space and that's nice because
if instead of going zero to six if you
go zero to sixty thousand still I have
the same equation I don't suddenly have
six million data points and in represent
so so so I representation doesn't grow
with the size of my iteration space it
grows with the shape of the iteration
space if you are complicated one it
be difficult okay so what you can do is
you can situation space is all
iterations I is 0 to 6 j is ie 27 and
these are all linear functions and that
means of analysis easier so the flip
side of that is the data space so if M
dimensional array has M dimensional
discrete Cartesian space basically in
the data space you don't have arrays
that are odd shape it's all almost hyper
cube always so something like that is a
one dimensional space and something can
be represent as a two-dimensional space
in li so data space has this nice
property in that sense it's hypercube
multi dimensional hypercube and what
that gives you is kind of a bunch of
mathematical techniques to kind of do
the analysis and transformations we need
to do in compile time as humans I think
we can look at lot more complicated
loops by hand and and and get a better
idea what is going on but in a compiler
you need to have a very simple way of
describing what what to analyze what to
formulate and having this model helps
you put it into a nice mathematical
framework and ooh so the next thing is
dependence we have done that so I will
go through this fast so the first is a
true dependence but that means is I
wrote something I read it here so
actually I really this meant that I
actually really use that value the other
two dependences mainly because we are
finding dependences on locations is an
anti-dependence that means I can't write
it until this Reed is done because I
can't destroy the value output
dependence is this ordering of writing
and then it maintained so so in a
dynamic instance there are dependence
exists between I&J if either inj is a
write operation and I NJ refers to the
same variable and I execute before Jay
so it's the same thing one execute
before the other so so it's not you
don't have a dependence going negative
in time they need to become either true
or anti so it's always going positive
time
so how about error accesses so one
element is easy you can figure out what
happens so how do you do dependence on
array accesses so now things get a
little bit compression because air is is
not one element so that is when you go
to a dependence analysis so i will
describe this using bunch of examples so
in order to look at arrays there are two
spaces I need to worry about one is the
iteration space one in the data space
what we want to do is figure out what
happens at every iteration for data and
what are the dependence is that kind of
summarizes it down we do not want to
look at say okay it when one one
iteration depend on second two different
and third you don't want to like least
everything we need to come up with a
summary that's what basically dependence
analysis will do so if have this access
this is a this loop what happens is as
we run down so it raises we are running
down here so there's iteration zero one
two three four five first to the read
write read dry so this is kind of time
going down here what you do is this one
you are right you are reading and you're
writing your reading and writing so you
have a dependence like that and you see
the true anti-dependence I read
anti-dependence I have anti-dependence
going on here so if you look at it here
is a dependence vector but that lease is
there is a dependence at each of those
things in the others anti-dependence
going on one way to look at summarize
that is what is my my iteration by
iteration goes like that what is my
dependence and he rent I dependence to
the same iteration because I am my read
and write as a dependency in the same
iteration so this is a way to kind of
describe that let's look at a different
one this one i did a i plus 1 equals a I
so what you realize is in iteration zero
you wrote inflation sero you wrote a
zero when you read a zero and you wrote
a one and an iteration 1 you read a 1
and wrote a a to basically
now what you have is you your dependence
is like that so in like that okay so if
you look at what's happening in here if
you summarize in here what tier is a
dependence going like that in iteration
space so in iteration that that means
iteration one is actually these are true
dependence that that uses something that
wrote instruction zero tuition to you
have something about intuition one
anyhow iteration going like that and
sometimes this can be summarized as a
vector of iteration dependence vector 1
that means is one because the previous
one was zero because there is no loot
crate dependence the outer loop there is
a dependence on one because it goes over
so if you have this one I plus 2 of
course it gets carried one across in
here and then you have one skipped
representation in here and if you have
to i 2 pi plus 1 what you realize is
there's no overlap so there's no
basically dependence in here okay so you
kind of get get how that Alice's goes so
so to find data dependence in the loop
so this is little bit of legally so let
me write there so for every pair of
array accesses so what you want fine is
a is there a dynamic instant that
happened that in iteration that rode a
value and another dynamic instance
happen that later that actually used
that value so the first axis in dynamic
so that there's a dynamic instance that
that road and access and another
iteration instance that also access the
same location later and one of them has
to be right otherwise is that are true
and n-type and and there's a notion
about the second one came after the
first one and you can also look at the
same awright so it doesn't have to be
the same a different array access a
merry access if you are writing if you
look at same a tech society you can have
output dependence also so so it's
basically it's between read and write
and write and write
good different rights can be the same
right to key thing is we are looking at
locations we are not looking at value
pass and say whose ex is in the same
location and loop carried dependence
means the dependence cross a loop
boundary so that means the person who
read and push and who wrote our
indifference a loop iterations if you in
the same iteration then it's all local
because in my tration I deal with that I
moved it around but if what I am writing
is used by somebody else in different
iteration I have looped carry dependence
going on and basic thing is if there is
a loop carried dependence that location
or parallelizable what that means is i
am writing in one iteration of the loop
and somebody is reading in different
iteration of the loop that means i
actually remove the data across they
cannot do happen in pattern that is a
very simple way of looking at that so
what we have done is ok that is a the
basic idea how do you actually go and
automate this process and the simple
notion is called data dependence
analysis and I will give you a
formulation of that so what you can
formulate this is using a set of
equations so what we want to say is if
there are two distinct iterations one is
a right tration one is a reiteration one
iteration rights value one iteration
reads the value so right iteration
basically writes a IW + 1 the read
iteration reads a I so we know both read
and write has to be within loop bounds
iterations because we know that because
you can't be outside loop round and then
we also make want to make sure that that
there's a lootcrate dependence that
means read and write can't be the same
iteration if she's in the same iteration
I don't have a loop credit dependence I
am looking for loop carried dependence
at this point and then what makes both
of the read and write write the same
location that means access function has
to be the same so the right access
function is IW + 1 and read access
function is I are so the key thing is
now we have set of equations
are there any values for inj integer
values no i dub sorry I wni are that
these equations are true if that is the
case you can say AHA there's a case we
are there's a iteration that that you
the right and read our writing into the
two different iterations one right
iteration 1 reiteration writing to the
same value and therefore there is a
dependence in it is this true is there
are values that makes this true
I mean you can do i equals I R equals 1
I w equals one and I are equals two and
and so there's value in there so these
three equations will come up with a
solution and also that the point you
have dependents does the important
restriction that these increase indices
can only be in action vehicles right
they happen and I mean so that that way
is easy to make this formulation so if
this in DC is calculated with some thing
or looked up I can write the formulation
right so so the way that I can do this
analysis is these indices has to be the
constant or induction asleep this is a
of B of I so if my array is a or b of my
icon I do I don't know how the number so
if you have a of B or pie I have no idea
about a is without knowing values of B
of I & B of I I can't summarize it each
B of I might be different and I can't
come up with this nice single
formulation that means i have to check
out a grill every be over and i am in
big trouble and this is doable but this
is not easy to like this
yeah yeah that's right so that's
interesting interesting that we are not
cooking it there yes yes because then
you summarize it because what you're
going to do is we are trying to
summarize for everything every iteration
and and and we are not trying to divide
it into saying okay can i find the
parallel groups yes I mean if you can do
some more complicated analysis and do
something like that yeah yes so other
interesting thing is okay the next thing
you want to do is to see whether we can
find output dependence and it's okay are
there two different iterations that
there's fighting the same thing and what
that means is the iterations I 1 I 2 and
I 1 not equal to i2 and i1 plus one
equals x 2 plus 1 obviously there's no
solution to this one because because the
I one has to be equal to i2 according to
this and I one cannot be equal to a
total in this one that says okay no I am
I don't have output dependence this one
because it can be set ok so here I know
I have a loop carried I haven't said the
true and tight depends on with direction
is a true anti-dependence but I don't
have a loop carried output dependence so
how do you generalize this so what you
can do is the integer vector I so we not
to generalize this we can use integer
program how many of you doing TJ program
will in a program okay yeah I do are not
going to go into detail but what I will
go tell you what actually happens so
integer programming says there's a
vector the variables I and if you have a
formulation like that is array a I less
than or equal to B be a and B L or
constants integers and and and and we
you can using integer programming you
can see that there's a solutions for I
or not ok this is if you do things like
operations research this is this lot of
work grounded people actually want to
know what value is why we don't care
that much much values we know we won't
just wanna know the solution owner and
if there's a solution we know that's
depend if there is no solution we know
there's no dependent so what you need to
do is we
you get the set of equations and put it
on that form that's not that simple for
example what we you know what is a I
less than less than P that means you
have constant a 1 I 1 plus a 2 I to
whatever whatever less than or equal to
B be meals anyway so you won't have this
kind of constant wave system not equals
doesn't really belong there so the way
you deal with naughty equals is you
divide into two different problems you
you can say I w less than I r is one
problem and I w is greater than I is the
other problem and if either problem has
a solution you have dependents so that
means one is true and 1's entice because
in the true dependence of
interdependence you can look at that how
was this one is a little bit easy this
is less than not it's actually less than
how to deal less sorry less than equals
less than equal how do you delete equal
so the where u is equal if you write in
both directions so a is less than B is
less than equal to b b is less than or
equal to a means actually is equal to B
so you can actually try two different
inequalities and get the Equality down
there so you had kind of massage things
little bit in here so here our original
Arab the iteration bounds and here's our
one problem because we are saying right
happens before read so these are true
dependence we are looking at and then
you and this is saying the right is
equal to happen right location is the
same as the relocation and is equal so I
have two different equations in me so I
can kind of massage this a little bit to
put it inside for and we can come up
with a snps okay so just just these are
just manual steps it's an base and now
you can say throw it into some super
duper integer linear program package and
it will say yes oh no and yourself and
of course you have to another problem
for the other side
and you can generalize it for much more
complete lewdness so if you have this
complicated lupinus in here you have
solved where n deepness you have sought
to end problems with all this different
constraint I just I'm going to go over
this I just have the slides in here aha
so that's kind of weird seeing a single
dimension so how about multi dimension
dependences so I have two different
ratio a two-dimensional iteration space
here and i have a i comma j equals a i j
minus 1 and that's my literature space
what does my dependence look like we
have the arrows cocoanuts which
direction is that was going so you have
something like this yeah so you have
something like this because this I'm i j
minus one where i saw the same of course
if you have the other way around go
other direction one is anti n 1 is a
true dependence so you can figure that
one out let do something complicated
first one so i J i minus 1 j plus 1
which has to be diagonal which diagonal
does it go this way or this way who says
this way who says this way ok so this is
actually going in this direction so this
is where you have to actually think meet
iterations actually write and read in
here so please get complicated okay this
one is very even more interesting this
one it's only one dimensional array or
two-dimensional loop nest so what that
means is who's writing and who's reading
if you look at it basically actually
this actually is little bit wrong
because the dependence analysis says
actually all these things all this
freeze has to go into all the rights
because because they are writing or any
j is writing the same thing so so this
is a little bit rob you this is actually
more for later flow analysis you see the
difference their dependence means I
don't care who's the last guy wrote
because he's the last guy who wrote that
everybody is feeling everybody else is
writing the same location
just keep rewriting the same thing again
in a game again it's so dependent on a
it's not dependent on jay's people are I
yeah but location says each of these
situations right in the same location
different Jays so no matter what Jay is
writing the same location you don't say
because changing j no this is iteration
space i am looking at infection i became
I NJ b is one dimension let it be so
one-dimensional it so what that means
the reason I'm saying is the iteration
space and erase paste I will correct
this and put it in India because this is
a data flow diagram its return trip and
what it says is this one is writing to
what a relationship is I anyways I have
I n is so this is right into what is 0
is actually this is writing to what bb1
all those things are ready to be one
okay and this is reading we will say so
this is vital to p 1 this is 3 DB 0 a
baby so this iteration is reading be one
again this will be 1 this is we shall be
one so it each of this writing to be one
each of these are reading from be one so
it has to be dependent from each other
why isn't it just qualified I wish to
have arrows going dialogue going down
the column means each is right into
different location so what happens is
that this one RS going down this Way's
is this one what road here is only that
location is this only this guy like
access this location these are all right
into the same location and reading from
the same location
this is iteration space you have two
different lupinus this is my problem i
can write this problem they said little
bit over stupid programs and kind of
same thing again and again five hey
program doesn't say you are a dimension
has to match you to dimension it does
say so you can have problems like that
you can have other way too and so so
that's the key thing is to make don't
confuse iteration space features erase
paste they are two different spaces two
different number of dimensions that's
all the pointers are going to make you
so by to independence analysis you can
figure out now can formulate this nicely
figure out with the loops apparel okay
so that's really neat and and the next
thing i am going to go is trying to
figure out how you can increase the
parallelism opportunities because there
might be cases where the original code
you wrote there might be some loops that
are not paralyzed about asses and can
you go and increase their so i'm going
to talk about few different
possibilities of do with that scalar
prioritization i'll just go in each of
these separately so here's the
interesting program i took a parallel to
the temporary and use a temporary in
here you might not have you and written
that what the compiler normally
generates something like that because
you always add temper racing here so
this might be quite compelling generate
is this no parallel
why is the loop carried dependence true
and what's the true dependence which to
eat let's say we then loop through
dependence what is the loop carried
dependence anti-dependence because i
cannot you say i equals 1 basically
wrote here and is reading i can't write
i equals 2x until i equals 1 is done and
time reading that i have one location
and everybody's trying to read the right
to that even though i don't really use
their this is the sad thing about this
so I'm not really use in this guys there
but I'm just waiting for the same space
to occupy and so there's a loop carry
dependence in here and it's
anti-dependence and so what you can do
is if you find any anti or output loop
credit dependent you can get rid of them
I'm not really using that bad well you
I'm just keeping a location in here so
how can we get rid of that that's one
thing the two ways of doing a while is a
decide something local so each processor
will have its own copy so I don't I
don't do that so something like so so I
don't have that score pieces restricted
in here oh I can allocate la if the
error you can have you the number of
process of iterations we each iteration
but uses a different location okay this
is more efficient by the way than this
one because you have touching lot more
locations in here I haven't done one
thing here I'm not complete whatever
yeah because it was beforehand somebody
might use X after end of the loop now so
what you had to do is you have to kind
of final I sex because i had a temporary
variable so you say this n the last
value has to go into X because you can't
keep just not calculating a value in
some sense so in here also you just last
well you get bit so if i do after you do
that basically now each of this loop is
powerful if we got that okay here's
another example x equals x plus a i do
we have loop carry dependence
what is the loop very dependency you and
I oh
so truly record this case actually
creating previous value and and adding
something anyway went so of course in
true dependence I cannot seem to
paralyze but there are some interesting
see we can do that was an associative
operation I didn't care which order
these additions happen because I'm just
keeping Eddie bunch of menus in here and
the results were never loop using their
the loop so we just keep adding things
at the end of the loop you get this some
totaling here and I never use any kind
of partial values anemia so that gives
the idea so what you can do is we can
transfer translate this into each of the
guys doing a temporary addition into its
own variable so each processor just do a
partial sum okay and at the end once
you're done you basically do the full
sum of course you can do a tree or
whatever more complicated thing then
that you can also capitalize this part
as a tree set free edition but you can
do that I mean Roderick talked about
this in a hand parallelization what we
are doing something very simple so is
compilers can figure out associative
operations and do that so this is where
all the people who are imperiling
paralyzing and all the people who are
right in the scientific code kind of
starting arguments but they said oh my
god you're you're doing operations and
it's going to have numerical stability
issues yes all true in compiler here
these flags that say okay just forget
about all these very issues most
probably to be light and most go little
worth it's okay so you might find that
problems too you run you change
operation order to get some parallels
and suddenly you get ready to numerical
stability some algorithms that you can't
do that but more celebrations you can so
here's another interesting thing so I
have a program like that two to the
power I and and of course most of the
time exponentiation is very expensive
and if you have smart kampala easily i
don't have to speak spanish a this thing
called strength reduction they say where
i made i will keep variable T this is to
the power i means basically every time I
I it by two and I can't keep any where
do you see why these two equivalent okay
this is good not a food compilers do
that but now what did I suddenly do yeah
I reduce the amount of computation of
piously but I just introduced a loop
carried to dependence in here because
now i have p depend on the previous t to
calculate the next value and while
overall sequential why species a win-now
son like and paralyzed and of course lot
of times what you had to do is we have
very smart programmer they say aha i
know this operation is expensive so i am
going to do this myself and create you
much simpler program in sequential and
the neutral paralyzes you can so what
you might have to do is kind of do this
direction transformation many times to
make the program run little bit slower
sequentially just so you can actually go
and paralyze it this kind of a little
bit counterintuitive you just look at a
program and say yeah there's a lootcrate
dependence i can do it little bit more
expensive in without the loop correct
dependence and the sun li i'm a loop is
parallel so there are might be cases
where you might have do it by hand and a
lot of compiler automatic paralyzing
comparison i do this also so just kind
of look at these kind of things and try
to move in that direction whereas mostly
sequential companies try to find these
and move in this direction so nice is
that
so another thing for array privatization
so scale as you I show you what we have
any hair anti and output dependence on
variable you need to privatize and in
arrays you have a lot more complexity I
am NOT going to go in that you can
actually do private copies also in there
okay you can do bunch of transformation
another thing people do is call
interprocedural parallelization so the
thing is you have nice loop and you
start analyzing loop and in the middle
of a loop take a function call suddenly
what I going to do with it you have no
idea what the function does and most of
the simple analysis is okay I can't
paralyzed anything that has a function
call that's not a gate parallelizing
compiler because a lot of loops have
function calls you might call some
simple as sine function Oh some simple
exponentiation frame and son needs not
paralyzed herbal and and this is a big
problem and there are two things you can
do one is interprocedural analysis and
one is in lining so the inter proceed
analysis says i am going to analyze the
entire program and as i have function i
am not going i am going to go and try to
analyze the function itself also and
what happens is so assume if a functions
are reused many many times so sine
function might be used hundreds of time
so every time you have call of a sine
function if you keep analyzing
reanalyzing what's happening inside the
sine function you kind of a exponential
blow-up so you have code size n you
might have you might have a exponential
time of number of lies need to be
analyzed because I recall need to go
there call some other functions you can
see the blow-up and so analysis might be
expensive the other option is you
analyze each function once and said yeah
okay I analyze this function once and I
every time I use that function i just
use that analysis information what that
means is you had a kind of summary of
what that function does for every curve
this is not that easy and this run into
thing called unrealizable path problem
because you go into function in 11 path
assume assume you call foo from here and
return here you corey here returns here
so when you analyze normally you can go
from here to here here to here but if
you treat
West only one thing you might be able to
even think that you can go here to here
and here to here this looks like one
thing in here you see that you control
comes here goes here come see a new
function called goes here because we are
not treating this as a separate instance
so while we are Eliza ng it once this
create this all this additional mass and
then can have problems in here so so
they say these are the kind of research
he thinks people are working on there is
no perfect answer these are complicated
problem so you have to do some
interesting balance in here so yeah
because other thing is every analysis
has to deal with that so you have to
kind of rewrite the entire compiler
which is not simple inlining is much
more easy if it is a poor man's solution
so every time you have function call you
just bring the function and just copy it
in there every time you have function
call you between the function and you
can run it to the same compiler but of
course you can have huge code bloat it's
not only in analysis expense you might
have a function that beforehand at only
hundred lines now we have millions of
lines in there and in trying to cash
problems all those other issues so can
be very expensive too so what people do
is things like selective in lining and
lot of kind of interesting combinations
of these finally loop transformations so
i have this loop so i have a IJ equals a
IJ minus 1 AI minus 1j so look at my
depend my arrow head looks little bit
too big there but look at my dependences
and is this Lou any of these parallel
yeah yeah yeah so asses neither you
can't paralyzed I because there's a loop
carry dependence in I dimension you
can't fertilize J because let's look at
dependence in jail dimension she has
idea because you can actually pipeline
so so pipelining we haven't figured out
how to paralyze pipelining stuff so the
way you can do the simplest thing called
loops giving you can kind of skip
because the iteration space is change
from a database you can come up with a
new iteration space that kind of skew
the loop in there so what it does it's
normally iteration space but this J
outside so you go execute like this and
the skill the loop basically say i my am
executing this way so I'm executing the
pipeline basically pipeline way so I'm
kind of going like this way executing
that way if I may cry if I can run that
loop in that fashion what I cannot I can
do is I can run this after this
iteration when you go to run the next
day iteration these are there's no
dependence across here if I run here I
don't have dependents in so i can run
each of these and then and i have
parallel set of iterations run so in
here what happens is this this inner
loop is can be parallel so it's
basically actually pipelining but it's
written in a way that i still have nice
two loops in here but i have done this
be a transformation another interesting
is garrett of parallelism assume i have
looked like that ing [ __ ] loop is
paneling here I go j j is better so okay
i do something like that i say i run i
envy I iteration I do barrier I runs a
parallel and I end up doing a barrier
again what might be problem in something
like this
I mean so inner loop parallelism can be
expensive because every time I I had to
do this probably expensive barrier run
few iterations for few in this one
probably only like few cycles and right
this very expensive barrier again and
everybody communicate move all those
things okay and at some most of the time
when you read a loop parallelism it
actually slows down the program you will
probably find it too sometimes if you
find the parallelism generally be too
small it actually has a negative impact
because all the communication need to do
synchronization you need to just over
when hell out of the program so in a
loop is expensive what are your choices
don't better life it's pretty good
choice for a lot of cases you look at
this and say this is a Cuban you mean
you basically by doing that oh can you
transform it outer loop parents taking a
loop pedal son that I change it so you
get out repels and this program is
actually nice there are complex analysis
you need to do to make sure that's legal
so you can basically take this one and
now a transfer pin the other direction
and what that means is you kind of do a
loop interchange now we instead of I you
have J outer dimension I inner dimension
in a loop and we need to do that you
what you have is here barrier and then
you can run this is parallel and this
like this and suddenly instead of having
n barriers for that loop we have only
one barrier so suddenly have a much
larger chunk you are running and this
can be run
okay so this is great so I talk to you
about all these nice transformation
stuff like that so at some point when
you know something is parallel you might
want to avoid generate parallel code so
the problem is depending on and how you
partition the loop bound sense has to be
change and I am going to talk to you
about how to get lube bounds so let's
look at this program so I have something
in here and and I am there's inner loop
that actually reach outer loop rights in
a loop reads and it's a triangular it's
a big mess now I assume I want to run
the I loop peddler so what that means is
I want to run the first processor
there's no over to this one this one run
modulation to iteration 34 whatever each
runs in here now how do I actually go
about generating code that actually does
that each each processor runs its flight
number of iterations this is a
non-trivial thing because it's
triangular each get something different
and you can assume all this complexity
one thing I did is my I my tradition
space if I and J this is my inequalities
representing iteration space so i assume
assume i am running a processor is
rationed run by a process you can say
you had in another dimension p and say I
equals P so I can look at now instead of
a two-dimensional space in a
three-dimensional space so in this
analysis if you can think
multi-dimension it's actually very
helpful because we can kind of keep
adding dimensions in here so what are
the loop bounds in here and what we can
do is use another technique called
foliar motzkin elimination to calculate
loop out by using projections of the
iteration space i will go through later
but to give you a flavor what it is it's
also if you are an integer linear
programming this is kind of extension
techniques on that so the way to look at
that is so
up okay here we go let's go okay
thinking either okay the top okay good
it's not a little bit too far one out I
didn't realize Mac and with this slow
day it's Monday Cena this how many cars
from the weekend death yeah exactly see
it takes you look good so this is
five-minute aneurysm if you think this
is very fast so what you can do is you
can think about this as this
three-dimensional space I J&P and
because is equal to P if you get I NP
you get a line in that dimension and
then Jay goes that so this is the kind
of iteration space in here and that
represents these so what I want is a
loop the outer dimension is P then the
next dimension is I and J you can think
about like that so what that means is i
need to get i get my iteration ordering
it happens in that you just go like that
how do i go about doing that so this is
the kind of loop nasai won't generate
let me go and show you how we generate
that so i just showed this thinking or
didn't get my key stroke it should i
press one more time not okay it's just
thinking all right so okay so here's my
space engine so first one I want to do
is my innermost dimension is J and what
i can do is i can look at this thing and
say what are the bounds of j so for each
the bounds of j can be described by with
recipe AP and I I shall show you how to
do that a little while and then i will
get j goes from 1 to i minus 1 and then
after that i can basically project it
and to eliminate j dimension so i am
doing is what i am doing Sam key to the
three dimension I project into two
dimensions without Jay anymore because
now I have left is I NP and I get a line
in that dimension okay then what I have
done I have to find I what are my bounds
of I
and bounce of I sexual i is equal to P
you can figure that one out this is a
line in there and then you eliminate I
and now you get this one and then what
our bounds of pp goes from basically to
wait you just basically get that so you
can do this projection in here let me go
in there and then now what you end up
doing is you can get this and of course
outer loop p is not a not a trail like a
loop you can say you get peace my ID p
is within this range I equals P do this
one so sunday i generate that piece of
code okay so i will go a little bit
detail and show you how this happens
free much skin happens so i want i have
my little bit of different space I am
bring a different projection I am doing
I JP I won't project first Iowa jo AAP
away instead of ji p before I did here's
my iteration space what do I do the
first thing I do is I found the bounds
of I so i have this thing i have just
basically expanded this and eliminate
the j1 lestat of this doesn't this one
doesn't contribute to the bounds of why
but everybody else so there are a bunch
of things that say I has to be less than
that and I have to be greater than these
two and then what i have is bound of i
is it has to be maximum of this because
it has been greater than all three so it
has to be max of this this set just be
less than these two it as we mean no
please question why don't you have to go
through all this at least in this case
the outer loop is very simple you could
have just directly myself this is very
simple thing but the problem is that's
because you are smart and you can think
a little bit ahead in there and if I'm
programming a computer i can't say find
these special cases so i want to come up
with a mathematical way that the
bulletproof way will work from the
simplest one two very complicate like
for example filing the loop bounds for
that that loop transpose that i showed
you before that that i know the sku that
had this that
she pointed out before so it's not it's
not so much just fine and indexed in
array on is to contest in the earth the
best index a nap yeah any could be issue
because you have for example if the
inner dimension depends on I and if I
goes outside then I can't make it depend
on I so if i have something like for for
now ieper something for j equals I to
something now if I switch this to a half
for Jay I can't say I to something I
have to get rid of I and I have to
figure out in there for I this has to be
something with Jay with some function
with jiaying here so that how do what I
says function how do you get that and
and and and and you need these kind of
transformations do that and I will next
I will talk you but can you do it a
little bit better okay so i get this
bout in here and then actually you found
is this is going from p2p so i can
actually share p because min and Max is
few and then after you do that what he
had two is you know you have to
eliminate I the way you eliminate I is
you take this has to be always less than
n and less than P so you take the abuser
there's n constraints am constraints
here and you get n times M constraints
clear in here so the first three has to
be less than and again we repeat it
again has to be less than P and then of
course the missing constraint that I 1
is less than J you put all those
constraints together and now the nice
thing is in that one is still legally
still represent that space but you don't
have I then you wish I get complete get
rid of I ok so by doing that and then of
course there are a lot of redundancy in
here and then you can do some analysis
and eliminate redundancy and you end up
in this set of constraints and that's
when you say what's the best you can be
best it has we correct but that means
you can't have additional iterations or
less iterations but best depends on how
complicated is the loop bound
calculation
that does not mean you can come up with
the correct solution and the bestest is
depending on how which order you do that
when you have two redundant thing which
one you eliminate so you can have lot of
heuristics saying okay look if this one
looks harder to calculate eliminate that
one was the other one so so you give
this set of constraints and then you
have to do is now find the bounds of j
so you have this setup is again to find
about you J is this only two constraints
are there and you know Jay goes to 12 p
minus 1 and you found a bond of J and
getting rid of j means this to only 21
the one gets then p minus 1 the two left
for pu put it there and then you can
eliminate the redundancy in here and now
you can found the bounds of p which goes
from 2 to n and suddenly you have the
loop mask so now i did a project idea
actually did parallelization and Anna
loop transposing here and i can combine
those two use this simple mathematical
way and found blue box in here okay so
I'm going to give you something even a
little bit interesting beyond that which
is communication code generation so if
you are dealing with the cash current
shared memory machine you are done you
generate code for parallel lupinus you
can go home because that's everything
else to be done on top but as we all
know in something like stealth if you
have no cache coherent shared memory or
distributed memory you do this this one
first then you have identified
communication and we generate
communication code okay and this
additional burden here so till now in
Sderot dependence analysis what we
looked at most locations centric
dependences which location is written by
processor one is used by processor 2
that's kind of very location centric
kind of view and how about if multiple
writes the same location as you may I we
show that an example if multiple people
write the same location which one should
I use that's not clear what you are
reducing the last guy who wrote that
location before I read read that
and that's not in this data dependent
flow analysis their dependence analysis
doesn't get it what you want is
something of a value century who's the
last right before my iteration who wrote
that location y know the last ride he is
the one I should be getting the value
fro if the last ride happened in the
same processor I am sad because I
brought to the local copy and I don't
need to deal with anything if the last
fight happened in a different processor
you need to get that value from the guy
who wrote it and say okay you wrote that
value give it to me if nobody wrote it
and I am reading it that means the value
came from the original array because
nobody read it Rock'em written between
my iteration that I am reading something
that is to come from the previous that
might raishin so I have to get it from
the origin in that way so but I have
these three different conditions so you
know to represent that are not going to
go into detail this a representation
called last right tree so what it says
is in this kind of a loop nesting here
you have some read access and write
accesses in here and if you look at it
location centric way you get this entire
complex graph because this is the graph
actually should have been in that
example why we give is all these errors
going in here except i'm shooting
notation before i was going other way
round Jay was in here so but if you go
look at value centric this is what
happens they say oh all these guys
basically got the value from outside
nobody wrote it this code from this is
the last time this is the last time this
is the last fight I actually have at my
last right information so where to look
at that is there are some part of the
iterations got value from some mail
other part groups of males you can't
kind of do a big summary as you point
out that kind of dependence depend on
where the trash answer so you can
represent it using a tree when it shows
up so you can say if j is greater than 1
here's the relationship between reads
and writes if otherwise relationship
means it came from outside so i can say
for each different places so you can
think about
this tree can be lot more complicated
tree so each part of the iteration space
I got data from some males so you get
this function i think i am going to the
next slide why is this slow okay wait
for my processor to do something this is
exceedingly so isn't it come on so what
you can do is now I have processes who
read process who write and iterations
that actually reading and writing one
thing i can do is i can represent it
using a huge multi-dimensional space so
what happens in here is the receive
iterations those are the iterations that
actually data has to be received in
communication in assume that the part
i'm actually communicating is also
within the loop bouts i can write that
and the last flight is a relation is
that i sin has to be i receive their we
know that and and what you have is what
the parallel basic processes this is I
iterations are parallel so processor
receive processor is running a litter
ation I precise send iterations are the
same because we will paralyze that to do
that that that loop basically in each
iteration get assigned to each processor
and of course you want to make sure the
process communication is non-local it is
local I don't have do communication and
I can't represent this as this gigantic
system of equality's has one two three
four five and there's a J receiver also
eating because the the harem of my I
think the program I wrote the original
program basically right happen in outer
loop and the read happen in an looks so
this only J receive the I sending here
if you could also that leader so so I
have five dimensions so I can't really
draw a Phi dimension but when I wait
until it
back I thought I bought a very fast
processor and supposing running a core
duo I have no idea what she's proud me
this far with some time out mechanism
waiting there somebody parallelized
somebody wrote really bad concurrent
programming here because not doing
anything is just waiting since something
timeout so what I have here is I have
this set of complete system of
inequalities for receive and in
combination and of course I since I can
draw five dimensions I and see since
these dimensions are the same I just
wrote it in the same so you can actually
assume that another two dimensions for
this one and that's a line in that
dimension so that's why this is my
actually this this is wrong sorry this
should be X I here written so so okay my
program is wrong sorry you see the I
think I hear it so now what we had to do
one more time it has to go so makes me
slow down my lecture so which is
probably good thing so you can see okay
there we go so what you can do is you
can scan this by projecting in different
ways to calculate the sin lupinus and
writable receive look and so if you scan
it that direction what you end up is
something saying for these processors
you need to send for this iteration is
this in this process for what we need to
send will be received by these
processors and this iteration and and
and this and this you care to send x I
to these iteration at this process so
you because because you have a that
relationship you can get the loop ness
that actually will do the same the same
way you can actually get lewdness to
receive when it shows up so what that
what that means is so all these guys
have to send all the situations has to
do the receive
come on this is very too slow actually
it was slow enough actually rebooted my
machine and then to get rid of all the
other kind of running junk okay there we
go it showed up sometime okay so if you
predicted in a different ordering what
you end up is you can say now for this
processor has to receive all these
processes have received something send
by these guys okay so now you can get
that cantaloop means for receiving anti
lupinus for sending and your computation
loop nest also the problem is you can
run them sequentially because you are
running some employee water so what you
have is something that next slide will
show we need aside so you have this
iteration there's some computation
happen from all the one and I will get a
loop pneus to do some say nein du plus
do some receives in one dimension also
this kind of you get three diff separate
things but of course what you have to do
is you have to generate code so the way
to do that is ok that so what you do is
you kind of break this apart into pieces
where things happens or this one or you
do computation this one you do
computation and receive and computation
send receive and whatever so it should
be probably send here and receive but
and for that one if you combine this you
get a complicated mess like this but
this all can be done very in this
automated fashion by using this for your
skin elimination and this linear
representation and of course you can do
a lot of interesting things on top of
that you can eliminate redundant
communication if you are keeping sending
the same thing again with that have any
change in it eliminate that you can
aggregate communication you do not want
to send a word at a time you can send
bunch of things into one my packet in
here you can do multicast so if same
thing is sent to multiple people it
doesn't help that but in in cell but
assume some machines a multi-car support
you can do that and also you can do some
local memory management because if you
have distributed memory you don't have
to allocate Oh everybody's memory and
only use a part you can say okay look
everybody only had allocate that
okay in summary I think automatic
parallelism of loops and arrays we
talked about data dependence analysis
and we talked about iteration and data
spaces how to do that and how to
formulate it as an integer programming
problem and we can look at lot of
optimizations that can increase
parallelism and then do that and also we
can deal with things like code complete
communication code generation and
generating lupinus by doing this for you
more screen elimination so what I want
to show out this talk is that in fact
this parallelization of automatic
parallelization of normal loop can be
done by mapping into some nice
mathematical frameworks and basically
manipulating the in that map so there
are many other things that really
complicates the life heck out of
paralyzing programs like see there are
pointers you have to deal with that so
there are lot of this problem is not
this simple but what compiler writers
trying to do know most of the time is
trying to find this kind of thing find
interesting mathematical models and do a
mapping in the end and then operating
that model and hopefully you can get the
analysis needed and even the
transformation needed within that kind
of a nice model so so I this kind of
gave you a good feel for general
parallelizing compilers we will take a
10 minute break and talk about stream it
if my we'll see what I can make this
computer run faster the meantime